breanne age of war Janowski be a
terrific and being satyr over at ESPN
espn.com will joins us here on the show
hi watch how are you I'm fantastic
the this Celtic story you know going
from down Gordon Hayward down Kyrie
Irving to now headed to the Conference
Finals where does this rank for you
among yeah I guess improbable storylines
in NBA in recent NBA memory well I think
I mean they've you know it's been a
really resilient group and and and a
deep a deeply talented roster I think
you have to give you know Danny Ainge a
lot of credit for the pieces he put
together here the versatility of the
rosters players who you know could play
multiple positions and and and really
mature young players jason tatum jaylen
brown who you know came into the NBA
ready to play and and ready to win it's
hard to win in the playoffs at that age
and frontline positions being counted on
it's rare i mean like there's a reason
typically you know teams want when teams
see themselves as contenders it's to try
to typically trying to do it with
veteran players and and to see a roster
that had obviously the filter on hayward
irving being now the conference final
against cleveland LeBron James with this
group is pretty remarkable
Jason Tatum as you mentioned he averaged
nearly 24 points per game in this series
his counterpart in this rookie draft
class the actual draft last marquel
volts couldn't get off the bench how
concerned are the Sixers about marquel
Foltz well listen I think you sort of
have to take it out of context of the
trade because they lost the trade
yeah because remember is you know Chris
it's not just it's not just fault
reverse tatum it's having giving up
another first-round pick another
potential lottery pick in that deal and
and that's typically
when you look at almost any sport you
don't see people usually trying to go
from three to Warren or from four to two
because the player there's got to be a
dramatic difference in those players
because again you're giving up another
pick so I think folks needs a big
offseason a summer where he can get into
summer league where he can continue to
work to get the range back in his shot
and to build back his jump shot you know
all the things that they drafted him for
in terms of his ability to get to the
rim and be explosive and strong and a
finisher in traffic I think they believe
that's all there but he's got to be able
to get you know really that full
functioning jump shot back that clearly
he lost over the course of last year but
it was a gamble of a pick it was a
gamble of a trade and you know still
he's fortunate that they have embiid and
they have Ben Simmons the camouflage
that deal because you know they're going
to continue to pay a price as they lose
another pick for it but you know for
them to at least get out of the first
round of the playoffs I think made that
less of a less of a storyline because
the team probably achieved more than
most of us thought they might in this
season do you fully understand Voltas
issue because it's always been a little
bit a little bit murky to me whether
it's injury related mentally do you
fully grasp exactly what went on within
the season well I think it was both I
think you just said it it was it was
physical it was mental you know Bret
Braun told me last week is as
challenging on the situation as he's
faced as a coach in the league and so
you know I think that they've been you
know I think there's been a lot of
opinions internally externally and how
they should handle it and how they did
handle it and you know he's going to
have to be
and the one thing Brown had said to me
about him is and I asked them if he
thought that he maybe was going to lose
and just lose him mentally or lose him
this year and he said that he felt that
there's an inner toughness there's a
strength to him that pulled him through
and that he thinks will keep kind of
propelling him forward but he's gonna
need that it's hard to be 19 years old
and number one overall pick and be a
player who can't get off the bench in a
playoff series who missed most of the
season you know they will label you
quickly in this league and he's got to
have to fight against hearing that
listening to that and then like maybe
allowing himself to get caught up in
those labels he's got to break through
that and so ultimately it's going to be
as faults to to push through this and
and build a career for himself dr. Ward
Janowski NB Insider ESPN joining me here
on the Dan Patrick show what kind of
changes to the Raptors make this summer
I think a lot of its gonna depend on
what they do with Dwane Casey because if
you if you're Toronto I think it's
probably hard to say we're just gonna
run it back exactly the same same coach
same core same team you could still do
that
but if you change coaches which they
haven't decided on yet then you can say
okay we're going to bring in somebody
else different philosophy different
style different scheme different system
and try that with this group or if they
keep case do they look at some some
changes III still think you know they're
young guys are going to get better and
you saw that this year the growth of
that young second unit they have and
then you know og has become a you know
became a starter for them he'll only be
better next year he was coming off an
ACL injury in college and and have the
full off season now the philosophies in
a train and he was terrific for them and
so if you can get growth there and that
group to continue to be better and
improve which would be a natural
progression you know but obviously for
where they want to go and
that's advancing in this you know to a
conference final to potentially an NBA
final you know it's still built around
lowry and derozan and and that's going
to be a big part of you know those guys
have to play better in those spots and
the postseason on both sides for them to
be able to do that now it's great to
talk to you which I appreciate the time
my friend okay Chris dr. food man that
you're having a hydrogen Oski and be
inside over the SPN for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]